we saw John Wick 4 last night and it was
incredible Dynamite action Exquisite
cinematography and Keanu Reeves is
breathtaking no you're breathtaking I
really
these movies are Head and Shoulders
above the Dead on Arrival straight to
DVD garbage action movies I usually
watch I mean I'd watch John Wick five
six seven I'd watch a hundred of these
things
hey what do you mean eh I'm just saying
eventually Keanu is going to move on
with his life and when he does I'm gonna
join him I disagree with my opinion yeah
oh it's wrong tell me more every single
John Wick movie raises my expectations
and then exceeds those expectations the
franchise is bulletproof it can survive
anything John Wick would not survive
Keanu leaving Keanu is Win let's put it
to the test then okay let's swap out
Keanu Reeves with another actor and see
if the franchise can survive any actor
oh no no not just any actor the
Cinematic equivalent of poison a man so
vile that he could single-handedly tank
a lesser franchise we're going to
replace John Wick with Steven Seagal
there's no better way to explain Steven
Seagal than to just show you Steven
Seagal in the 90s he starred in a bunch
of forgettable action movies and quickly
gained a reputation not for being a good
actor but for being a terrible human
being you're that guy don't hate many
people but that guy I hate that's
actually that's a strong feeling good
call so you want him in John Wick too
since then every one of his movies has
lowered our expectations and then failed
to meet those expectations if he's
gotten lazier and lazier I'm gonna pitch
you some tropes yeah you can put them in
the category of Love or hate as he gets
fatter his clothing becomes longer and
looser to hide the shame I love kind of
cookies honestly I love that yeah it's
kind of fun I will do the same thing
yeah yeah so I'm gonna throw that in
life yeah he basically just wears bags
he weren't steeply hurt me he's creepy
and inappropriate towards younger women
strong distance
that's in his real life and on camera he
writes his own films so what you're
saying is in anything that we see coming
up it's from his mind and heart that's
exactly right and he wanted him to say
it okay all right I will snatch every
[__] birthday what does that
mean over time he has developed an
African-American accent I hate it how
come you don't watch any Oscars tonight
he got 15 [__] and guns and you
know it let me tack up let me tack up
another Trope very incoherent I'm coming
to the side door sharp I need you to
look at the Target room on the eighth
floor
he uses body doubles for action scenes
that are much fitter than him oh there's
a oh yeah yeah he just gets everyone
else to do the cool stuff for him and
then he just kind of Pops in at the end
he will use stunt doubles for scenes
where he's walking he's not doing any
kind of action but he's just like
couldn't be bothered to do the shot does
he take credit for doing his own stunts
oh
he's a huge narcissist and pathological
liar he exaggerates his accomplishments
and interviews and this kind of goes
back to the stunt man thing right does
he hit them
um I feel like he hits them you can
stack punches you can sell punches
without actually making physical contact
he does it he actually just hits them as
hard as he can and uh something don't
want to work with him that's a negative
so here's an action scene Segal claims
to be an Aikido Master but I would call
that uh more of a silly slap
relax
okay so I'm gonna skip the Putin stuff
so he lazily handles firearms on screen
he will just hold things wrong look at
this switch oh man yeah look at this
lazy sloppy gun handling he's barely
looking at where he's shooting ever just
like blindly firing into a crowd
sometimes so now he has a knife and he's
waving it like it's a sword
look at this I used to do that when I
was eight another thing he doesn't like
to stand up this is called sniper
special ops no no colon Steven Seagal
found a way to be seated for pretty much
all of the movie I'm around where I'm
supposed to be that's very strong in the
love category in action how do you stand
out sitting down you don't stand at all
look at him just fighting sitting down
what is this Crouching Tiger sitting
dragon
now when he does sometimes get out of
his seat
um he has a run
and it is a very very strange run
[Music]
the windmills like this the other one
sort of goes out has to get out of there
though
yeah it is you know what this reminds me
of this reminds me of John Wick
Steven Seagal has always survived
through all of his terrible movies with
somehow without being canceled it's a
story of survival yeah I like that yeah
it is uh and so that's why I kind of
think that like a Steven Seagal would be
a perfect star for the John Wick series
I'm in are you in
you've been watching so much the gall
that now your motor skills are starting
to fail I don't do my own stunts dude I
have to retake that one take two okay so
now that we know who Steven Seagal is
what would a John Wick trailer look like
with Steven Seagal how do we achieve
that well I honestly I just have to sit
down and watch way too many of his
movies
I looked at a lot of Clips actually
sitting down and watching these movies
it is a chore there's got to be a
shortcut it's a man called space ice he
has actually done the hard work for me
the brutal brutal task of actually
watching all of these movies so now what
I have is 10 Steven Seagal movies and
three of the John Wick movies now my
goal is to scrub through those films and
figure out a way to Frankenstein them
together in a way that is uh coherent
and funny and also just pays off the
John Wick Universe this is not a Segal
movie this is a John Wick film with
Seagal in it so you might remember this
shot of the late Mrs Wick from John Wick
one Segal wouldn't have any part of that
he doesn't care about women what he does
care about is one man
I like the shirtless one the most look
at him lounging so every John Wick
trailer needs a cool suit up scene
an Italian classic I have to figure out
a way to get Seagal in the shot the real
trick with shots like this trying to
find something that has a similar enough
lighting and really just like a gesture
something that like kind of feels like
they're interacting I took Seagal waving
doing this little point and then this is
what it looks like together so that
works you may remember in one of our VFX
RS react episodes his face is very
poorly comped on to a stunt actor as
he's riding a motorcycle
wait a second we're not I kind of wanted
to just sort of pay homage to that but
also spice it up a little bit there's a
great one from John Wick 2 and it's a
close-up of his face so this is perfect
for us at that point all I needed was a
still image of Steven Seagal got out and
motion tracked
ever a Steven Seagal sing-along this is
what would be bouncing on the words yes
why is he Wiggly it's because we put him
in this scene dude you already have done
such a better job at motorcycle helmet
coughing than what I've seen honestly
the big thing that sells it is the
reflections like pulling the original
Reflections from the other dude's face
nice on a micro level it's a lot of
comping but on a macro level it is all
about the story you know the John Wick
World exists with motivation the
inciting incident of the John Wick
series is that these Russians killed the
man's dog what could you take away from
Steven Seagal that would disrupt his
life more than anything what does Steven
Seagal really care about what comes to
mind takeaway is Comfort that's right
yep what does that look like what does
that look like you take his chair
the chair is sort of like John Wick's
dog it gets busted up by a bunch of
criminals we need a shot of this chair
getting busted up by a bat and the best
way to do that is just freaking beat a
chair with a bat and that's what we're
gonna do
[Music]
chair wants the break we've pre-cut this
chair to be shatterable Derek is Batman
today to me it makes the most sense if
it's like right here the guy who made
this chair is for sure dead so if you
[__] up there's no redos we got one
opportunity to cease everything we ever
wanted on this one will he capture it or
let it slip three two one
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
I'm not looking I'm not looking still
he's been working on this behind my back
like literally because I'm right here
um for like a couple of days and he's
told me not to look until this moment so
all right Matt America it's gone through
so many changes the good the bad the
ugly is a film that was released here a
while ago Steven Seagal fled the country
I think so he's not here but what we
have now on American soil is his CG
replica hand crafted somewhat I also got
a model on sketchfab that was pretty
good but I built on it you know and now
we can gather we can watch we can point
hand in hand as a country and say don't
like him I don't like that guy that
guy's weird he has an ego problem
and I'm hoping that that will heal this
nation this Seagal is stronger faster it
hasn't committed any atrocities or
crimes we can do anything now once I'm
done connecting my body to the Mainframe
I'll be capable of great feats Feats
even the real Steven Seagal could only
hope to achieve
like standing it's the same joke it's
the same joke
[Music]
you're not threatened by anything yeah
you don't need to get up the scary thing
is the more I sit the more I want to and
I'm kind of understanding how this
happened
[Music]
storms too
pull the dog over a pool his right hand
and his left hand are on two different
planets there's a lot of elements to
this that I didn't really expect when I
first watched these Matt and I worked
very hard to capture the essence of
Steven Seagal via mocap and the first
thing I did was throw it all away
because I realized very early on that
the average human body cannot replicate
Steven Seagal's run it's he's built
different we're gonna do something else
entirely and I used what's called
secondary motion inside of Houdini
there's this really cool tool called
secondary motion which basically delays
certain bones it's almost like it kills
all the muscles in the arm and you're
left with just the segoli and flip and
it actually worked out really well so as
he's running I kind of have a mixture of
hand animation and just natural
secondary motion flip so we've got our
nude Seagal running in his big boy boots
and that's a beautiful thing you know if
you're if you're broken inside but what
we need is the clothes we need that next
level the way that we did that was in
Marvelous Designer it's essentially like
a tailoring software where you can
generate clothes from scratch or you can
buy certain outfits you can simulate
animations wearing those outfits it's a
really high level cloth simulating tool
and now as you can see he is wrapped up
in his clothes that are deforming really
nicely and moving along with his motion
the idea of secondary motion really
comes back here because it's those
little details that take away from the
cginess of something in my opinion you
know but of course then we've still got
one issue and that's his ponytail very
rich you're just not doing anything and
I wanted to introduce a little bit of a
flop well that's something I did inside
of Houdini using Vellum Vellum is
essentially Houdini's soft body
simulation solution the final step in
bringing this home it's the idea of
generating hair if I'm looking at a
silhouette of Steven Seagal with a
strong Rim light and it's just a smooth
greased hair actually that'd be pretty
real too
it's pretty smooth and greased now that
I think about it I might have wasted my
time on this one
regardless I wanted to do it so that's
why we did it I just isolated those
areas and instant short hairs on top of
it and a lot of them at that probably
about a million or so and by the way if
you're interested in character animation
there is an hour-long episode of our
crutorial series on Corridor digital.com
it explains how you can Reagan anime
characters of your own just like this
sign up for an account if that tickles
your sagali and pickle so at the end of
this you have a run animation a cloth
animation you have hair animation and
hair simulation on top of throwing on
some glasses throwing a gun in their
hand and all those other fun little
elements that kind of bring this thing
home I mean it just goes to show you
that secondary motion can help and
sometimes even save animation the same
way that Keanu saved these movies
so once this thing's created we're gonna
let the audience decide you know we're
gonna let the people decide yeah does
this need Keanu or
is it a keanu-free franchise I'm gonna
take this whole thing
on purpose John Wick needs our boy far
more than our boy needs John Wick and
I'm going to illustrate that point by
bringing the darkest elements of Seagal
into this franchise and poisoning it
from the inside out during the
simulation of the cloth I made sure to
loosen the belt so to speak and I let
gravity do the rest oh
[Laughter]
do you try to sabotage this whole
mission statement I'm just trying to
bring realism Matt like at the end of
the day if we are going to put Seagal in
John Wick we are going to put all of
Segal in John Wick Kraken all throw it
in there I don't care I know you're
trying to sabotage this whole operation
the franchise will hold up the way
Seagal's pants don't Matt's very
confident right now but he's forgotten
the most important thing of all
crack kills
crack kills oh you heard me I did yes it
wasn't very quiet I felt like I was
whispering no I'm right here
there's a couple things that we need
aside from the visual effects though we
need a Seagal yes impersonator
[Music]
it's definitely a feigned deep voice one
of the iconic features of his voice is
the compressed diaphragm don't stand up
when you when you do any of your your
lines uh it's very important for the
character got it brother
all right please mayor you want the
antithesis of Steven Seagal it's Brett
yeah it's the sun nothing brings the
warmth quite like the sun yeah that's
right
foreign
[Music]
there are people out there and we have
to sell them a ticket to this movie only
one thing left to do jack up all right
sorry guys it's gonna take a second
sorry in your hands you have a gold coin
that gold coin is worth 18 real human US
Dollars would you spend that money to
see a two hour version of this thing or
would you keep your money and go home
enjoy
friends extremely young women
it's not what you did son it's who you
did it too
just assassin to ever leave I'm a
professional killer handsome wise and
articulate once I've been almost
confirmed we were in there you can take
him out away from my word he's also
really good at guitar and he did it all
sitting down
what they done have you returned to the
fold my brother if I get back in I need
resources let me tack up wait
it's ending no I'm running
you run you die you gotta tell me
straight so I can know who's coming for
us our pleasure
it's like a monkey trying to [__] a
football now really what have you done
we've just succeeded inverting these
[__] to the ground
you uh working again yeah
thinking I'm black
this thing is a would be a rare Jam if
it was made I would gladly watch it it
would be the worst greatest movie I've
ever seen that's one it's a very
enticing trailer but I'd probably be
feeling some crime overseas so I'm gonna
split the death of Nick
if you wanted to see a matinee together
I would not watch Steven Seagal in a
John Wick movie now but after watching
that I just know he sucks now do I agree
with who this man is absolutely not but
I gotta respect the craft that's a good
trailer the butt crack part didn't put
the butt crack was the reason I'm doing
it I backfired does Steven Seagal get
any of this coin let's just say he's uh
pro bono money does funny things when
Stephen touches it you don't know where
it ends yeah I'm not taking that risk
this is just mine
um
when that hip-hop beat kicks in I was
genuinely kind of hyped you know what
else so I'm gonna wait for the streaming
service oh wow I'm gonna spend about
five of this on the Walmart DVD bin so
I'm just gonna put that kind of like on
the edge it's free money so yes I'm
gonna go watch this movie
that was the best thing I've seen in a
long time and the hardest thing to
understand
so this was not close you created a
monstrosity that people actually want to
see Keanu Reeves yes I fought for you
yeah I really tried
I thought the crack would kill this
whole thing but it made it stronger
no no no
I'm seriously so sorry
this is devastating so I think what you
guys showed here is that at the end of
the day it's the craft that really
matters
a good movie with a good plot it almost
doesn't really matter who is in it but I
do personally think that the artist does
matter behind the art you know and to
support people who are good people and
do good things if you can work with
anyone you might as well work with good
people who do a good job
[Music]
and remember ladies and gentlemen can't
place a crumb let's give a round of
applause for these gentlemen it's
beautiful beautiful
[Music]
that was a small sample size and we want
to know what you guys think
comment down below would you
John fake in theaters and like And
subscribe it helps us out
[Applause]